I hate the winters in Boston I was
getting ready I went to get a new jacket
the other day I went to the expensive
mountain store place near the mall and
I'm looking at this coat and it's way
too much money but then the kid says
it's made out of gore-tex sir
and I said gore-tex what do I need with
gore-tex he goes all you got to have
gore-tex gore-tex is the most water
resistant fabric known to man you could
climb to the top of a mountain in a
hailstorm if you were wearing this
jacket you wouldn't feel any moisture at
all and I said wow that's pretty
impressive let me ask you this though
how does it handle gravy because in my
world that's a much more likely scenario
I don't have a whole lot of mountain
climbing planned you know but there's a
good chance I'll be driving home with
Boston Market with a chicken pot pie in
my lap long story short I now own a
gravy resistant gore-tex eating jacket
yeah I like to eat when I'm driving to
eat when you drive yeah my wife's got a
new car and I'm not supposed to eat in
it but I do yeah cuz she's got the
heated seats and you can use those to
warm up what you're gonna eat you ever
try that you take like a regular ham and
cheese sandwich sit on that for like
seven miles
ha try it and make sure you're wearing a
corduroys get the little grooves in it
make yourself a nice little panini
sandwich on your way home from work yeah
I live in the suburbs I got a I got a
nitwit neighbor he's got bees in the
backyard not a few bees buzzing around
boxes of bees five boxes of bees 50,000
bees in a box and I'm living right next
to a quarter of a million bees one fence
away and I don't know what you know
about bees they don't give a [ __ ] about
fences that's an arbitrary line they fly
right over no respect for the feds to be
you know what a fence does when you live
in next to a quarter of a million bees
gives you one less direction in which to
run when you get attacked by a quarter
of a million bees and I don't know why I
even have bees right so I ask him I go
what's the deal with the bees and this
is what he says to me he goes well we're
saving all kinds of money on honey
and I went yeah I guess you got a point
I never thought of it that way but now
that you mention it just the other night
I was sitting down at the kitchen table
going through the bills and right now
the checks screaming at my wife saying
we're spending too much money on honey
in this house that's six dollars you
spend every four years on a plastic bear
full on he's killing us we got to get
some bees and get off the big honey grid
this is unsustainable
my wife's watching too much of that
Shark Tank show you like that show the
shark tank yeah it's a great show but
she's watching too much here so I know
she's watching too much the other night
I tried to get her to go upstairs and
fool around you know I go hey honey you
want to go upstairs to fool around and
this is what she says to me she goes
well I'm very tired and I have to get up
early tomorrow so for those reasons I'm
out
[Music]
very cozy when we do get in the bedroom
though
very romantic yeah we get an electric
fireplace up there it's very romantic
but it's a dry heat
so we had to put a humidifier in the
other side of the room got this thing
spitting up mist all night and I got an
old house I got drafting windows I got
cold air coming in through there and
there's a ceiling fan above the bed
mixing everything up yeah I don't know
what you know about meteorology but I
got potential for a nor'easter to come
ripping through my bedroom at any given
moment which is why I sleep in gore-tex
now so
[Music]
my wife's very sexy in the bedroom she's
very chatty in the bedroom yeah not not
before not during but after she wants to
talk about it and I gotta be honest with
you at that point I'm done I don't want
to talk about it I don't even want to be
there anymore
I'm like coach Belichick at a press
conference at that point you know she's
going wasn't it great wasn't wonderful
did you enjoy it I'm going happy to get
out of here with a win we had a good
week of practice made some adjustments
at the half let's look at that tape on
Monday and see if there's room to
improve right now we got to get some ice
on the Gronk and we're on to my birthday
[Applause]
you